[Music]
my name is Jonathan Weiss I am the
founder and CEO of Oswalt's middle audio
is known as oma and we're in our Dumbo
Brooklyn showroom surrounded by all of
our products we're really an outlier in
the high-end audio world we make
everything from the signal source in
terms of analog that's record players
which we make out of solid slate we make
our own line of tube amplifiers and
we're the only company in the world that
makes conical horn loaded loudspeakers
for high-end home use we make everything
so that we have total control over the
sound one of the first phases to our
products is coring the slate and this is
a very special slate because it's it's
actually very soft which from an
acoustic standpoint is really desirable
it dissipates vibrations and residences
extremely well
much better than harder sleep so when
they are quarrying the slate then the
literally is hand tools to cleave off
sheets which break off and then are
placed on a truck or taken with a
gondola into the main fabrication part
of the quarry where a huge diamond saw
with water is used to cut these cleaved
off irregular pieces of slate the last
stage is honing and putting a very fine
edge or bevel so that it doesn't chip we
use cast metal in a lot of different
products all foundries they have a
furnace the metal is put in solid form
into this VAT and it becomes molten like
just out of the movie Terminator but
it's poured into this sand mold it goes
in hardens the sand is rusted away and
you have a rough cast in which then goes
through the various finishing processes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
then has to be welded edge treatment
after that that's accomplished then it
goes to be powder-coated where it
literally is baked and cured like into
the super hard durable finish
much better than paint all of our
loudspeakers have steel stands or
infrastructure and all of those elements
are powder coated the Millis is is
essentially our laboratory
it's our reference listening space it's
where we can put elements new and old
together listen to them evaluate them
and decide what direction we want to
take with new products and new
technologies there are things that would
never surpassed in terms of sound
quality the industry has moved in ways
that are not about the ultimate sound
quality but about size convenience and
cost and none of this stuff is
convenient small or cheap but it does
represent the best sound that's really
ever been been made
all of our loudspeakers are made out of
Pennsylvania hardwoods and these are all
woods which Martin guitar which is the
world's best acoustic guitar company
they're right across the valley these
the same woods that we just saw I know
that they're totally great woods at that
point it comes into our woodworking shop
where it's cut down further into boards
of varying thickness and width which
will be joined together to create
loudspeaker enclosures amplifier
enclosures horns all using meticulous
hand-done joinery that allows the wood
to expand to contract in your home it's
like a living thing this is a very
difficult time-consuming expensive
process we're the only company in the
world that does this number nobody else
makes loudspeakers using solid wood
joinery construction not today not that
I know ever
[Music]
at a certain point the parts come from
the woodshop metalworking shop how to
code they come to our central facility
where we do the final assembly most of
our equipment it's very big and it's
very big because it has to be sine waves
can't be miniaturized it's physics
that's very old-school that mass
production
and the components that we use are
simply that the highest grade possible
the aerospace level stuff the last phase
is really our installation of the
equipment in our clients homes or
wherever they're going if you have an
amazing system and you put Elvis on it's
frightening it's like he's right there
[Music]
what the system is doing is it's taking
the energy that came out of Elvis
literally sound waves are energy so it's
taking that energy and it's reproducing
it so perfectly that you have this
uncanny feeling that somebody's there
that's been dead a long time
that's what amazing sound quality is
you
[Music]
you